talk but that saves substantive
questions towards the end just to
protect the flow
um and to make sure that she doesn't get
stuck on the first five minutes of the
talk which can sometimes happen if we
all start jumping in because i'm sure it
will be quite provocative so with that
um alice it's a pleasure to have you
here please take it away
okay thank you so much deardra and
thanks again to the organizers as well
for the invitation
to join today's session so let me just
quickly share my
[Music]
screen you can
see my slides
yes we can okay great awesome so
hi everyone my name is alice young and
i'm the global head of ai ethics at sony
so i lead our research lab on ai ethics
and also our team that conducts ai
ethics assessments and today i'll be
speaking on algorithmic fairness and
interpretability and specifically um
i'll be presenting two works in progress
one
is on causal fairness and the other is
on
diversity metrics for human image data
sets
so
let's go ahead and start with the first
paper which is promises and challenges
of causality for ethical machine
learning this is joint work with ida
talabi who is also in the audience today
and
ida
is a new research scientist on my team
and also was one of our interns last
summer
and basically in this paper we take a
potential outcomes framework approach to
causal fairness and talk about some of
the advantages and also some of the
shortcomings of this sort of approach
and so first just to set the context so
typically when we're thinking about the
machine learning context we're thinking
mostly about prediction and trying to
develop the best predictors and this
doesn't necessarily always require
consideration of the underlying causal
mechanisms in our data sets
that said now that we're in a state
where machine learning is increasingly
being used not just for predictive
purposes but also to guide decision
making
we have to think a bit more about the
fact that historical data can be subject
to discrimination and can reflect
historical discriminatory trends
and that such trends often
operate in a very multi-layered
multi-stage way
and so within this context it's quite
important that we actually identify and
delineate different sources of
discrimination in order to mitigate
unfairness in our
models
and so just as a brief overview of some
existing approaches to
fairness so we can roughly divide them
into statistical or observational
criteria
and causal criteria and so observational
criteria in this case rely exclusively
on observed data distributions
whereas causal criteria also rely on
counter factual outcomes
and there are some pros and cons to
these different approaches so
um on the observational side of things
of course the the main challenge which
is what we want to tackle um in this
paper is identifying different sources
of disparities is quite difficult with
observational criteria
and there's also challenges in terms of
conflicting definitions and
in particular there's very famously
impossibility
theorems in this context where many
popular statistical notions of fairness
cannot simultaneously be achieved under
certain assumptions
and then
on the flip side though the advantage of
such observational criteria is because
they only rely on the observed data
distribution they can be quite easy and
straightforward to evaluate
in contrast with the causal criteria
because counterfactual outcomes are not
directly observed we do need to make
strong assumptions in order to impute
such counter-factual outcomes
and in addition when we're talking about
the algorithmic fairness context in
order to actually create counter-factual
outcomes we need to think very carefully
about manipulation of immutable
characteristics um like
race gender
age that are often the um the attributes
that we're interested
in from a discriminatory perspective
of course the whole purpose though of
going through all this is our hope is
that um
even
given these challenges
we are able to use these types of causal
criteria to identify sources of
disparity
and so the contributions of this
work are first to
shift some of the focus from intervening
on the immutable attributes themselves
to the perception of these immutable
attributes
and this is already something that is
done in the social science context um
greiner and rubin famously proposed this
in terms of evaluating discrimination
in the non-algorithmic context
and in particular this also shifts a lot
of the focus in terms of being very
precise in defining the timing and
nature of the manipulation of the
perception of the
um
of the sensitive attribute and so
by defining how you're actually changing
that perception that in turn can affect
the type of causal effect you're
actually able to estimate
and also in the process of determining
the timing of that intervention that
also determines what sorts of
discriminatory actors
effects you can actually
measure
and so this is quite important um
insofar as we might be wanting to
pinpoint the precise source of bias
we also propose based on this approaches
for unfairness evaluation and mitigation
and we also introduce some causal
variants of common statistical criteria
and show that there's no fundamental
incompatibility between them unlike in
the case for statistical criteria
and so in terms of
um illustrating this a bit and i won't
be able to go through all of the points
in this paper unfortunately today
because we also have the other paper to
go over but
first just to start with a toy example
to build some intuition
um so let's say we have some sort of
hiring process and at a certain point we
have the perception of the applicant's
gender
and this is what we would like to
manipulate in order to say if this
person were perceived to be a different
gender would they have had the same
hiring decision
and mapping this out on a timeline is
quite important because
we want to distinguish between
covariates asks that are determined
before the perception of gender versus
x tilde of a
and y of a which are things that happen
after the perception of gender and thus
are a function of them and so let's say
that the gender is perceived at the
point of the interview process
in that case we have to consider um
interview score to be a post-treatment
variable and if we want to
consider that in
in estimating any causal effect we have
to very specifically model the
relationship between a and x tilde
in contrast
if instead we are not trying to include
discrimination that might be from the
interview itself but instead we want to
measure the effect of discrimination
after the interview process
then we can consider x-tilde to be a
pre-treatment variable and thus
we can actually use that information
more directly
and so in terms of
what kind of
unfairness evaluation we might do in
this context so from a causal
perspective what we're interested in is
the expected difference between people's
potential outcomes if their attribute
was different
and so you can say causal parity then
is um
implies that the decision-making process
is fair if this expected difference is
zero
um of course in order to do any causal
inference in this context to actually
impute the other potential outcome that
we don't observe there are some
pretty
strong assumptions that sometimes
that we must make um
i mean
they are sometimes very strong
assumptions and this is important to map
out because oftentimes in papers people
will just um sort of say these are the
assumptions and that that is a caveat
but if we want to actually use this um
sort of methodology for
um
for making inferences about fairness we
need to be quite rigorous in terms of
actually evaluating whether these
assumptions hold in a particular case
um so these assumptions are
first off sutfa so this is the stable
unit treatment value assumption
so basically this means that the
treatment of one individual does not in
turn change the potential outcomes of
other individuals
and
this is not always the case um indeed
sometimes especially if we're thinking
of
a market you know perhaps um
how other people are perceived and in
turn the
hiring decisions of other people might
affect whether there's still places
available for you to be
hired for that same role
and there's also
consistency so there needs to be only
one version of each treatment
so this can also be limiting and say you
know there might be
we might not only have gender
discrimination as a binary so perhaps
there are different layers if someone is
non-binary or someone is trans and so
we would want to very explicitly model
every relevant type of
treatment
there's also positivity so at each level
of pre-treatment variables the
probability of
receiving any treatment must be strictly
positive
and then finally we have conditional
exchange abilities so we don't have any
unobserved confounders that affect both
the treatment assignment and the
potential outcome
once we condition on the pre-treatment
variables and again this
depending on the data you have available
in the scenario can be quite a strong
assumption
um so in terms of how we actually try to
assess
unfairness in this context so of course
this is quite easy if we actually had
access to both potential outcomes we
could just very quickly
calculate the difference for every
individual and
take an average and then we would have a
nice estimate
but in practice we only ever observe one
potential outcome for each individual so
in terms of imputing the other potential
outcome
there's many different methods that can
be used in this case what we do is we
choose one of the groups as a baseline
group so in this case perhaps the men
are treated as a baseline and then we
train a model for the probability of
being hired conditional on certain
pre-treatment attributes if you are
treated the same way as
the male individuals
and then we can apply this to the female
individuals to impute
what their hiring decision would have
been if they were treated in the same
way as the male individuals
and so in this way
we can try to
start answering that question of
but for an individual's gender would
they have been hired and in this way
hopefully we can
develop inference that also maps on to
how people think about discrimination in
the legal context
um so in our paper we also go through
and um develop some causal equivalence
of many of the common statistical
fairness notions like parity calibration
positive predictive parity and equalized
odds um i won't have time today to run
through all of these
but instead i'll illustrate this a
little bit in uh um
in a numerical way in the numerical
results we derived from
a synthetic example using these sorts of
metrics
so basically we synthesized some data
here where we have um several different
sources of disparity that we want to
distinguish between using causal versus
statistical notions of fairness
and in the synthetic
hiring scenario we have alpha which is
the level of disparity in the job
qualifications between the two different
genders
for the sake of this toy example we just
have two groups in terms of gender
and then we have beta which is the level
of disparity in the interview score for
the level of job qualification and so
this is one form of bias this is bias in
the interview process and then we have
gamma which is the level of
discrimination in the job decision
conditional on the job qualification and
interview score so this is um yet
another form of bias this is the bias
that occurs after
the interview process
and we also consider in this two
different starting points for the
unfairness evaluation before the
interview and after the interview in
order to distinguish between beta and
gamma and so these are the
numerical results we get from these
experiments and so basically on the
x-axis we have beta which is the
discrimination in the interview score
and then on the y-axis we have the
fairness evaluation that we measure and
we have three different cases here for
different levels of alpha so this is a
baseline where there is no difference in
qualifications across gender
and then these are where one of the
genders have higher qualifications
and first
i want to point out that so for causal
post which is the green
line it's flat throughout which makes
sense because basically that's when we
evaluate bias after
the interview process and since beta is
biased in the interview process
that should be flat throughout so it's
flat but non-zero because it's
reflecting gamma which is the bias
outside of the interview process
for causal pre and statistical though
what we would ideally like to see
is that
the bias should increase with beta since
for those two metrics we're trying to
measure
both the bias from beta and also from
gamma
and the bias should be non-negative
ideally
and so
when we look at the scenario where there
are no disparities in qualifications
between the different genders we see
similar trends
for causal pre and statistical so we
can't compare apples and apples apples
to apples the actual um
the actual axes exactly so you should um
so we don't need to worry too much about
the exact slopes
or the exact intersection with the
y-axis but we can see the trends are the
same in terms of starting
at
a fairly low level of bias that's
positive and then going up with beta
this changes however and the two types
of metrics diverge when we have
differing baselines between the
different demographic groups
and so in the scenario where females
have higher qualifications than males
in this case the causal
pre
still has quite similar trends to what
we saw
before in that we have positive
levels of fairness violation for all of
these and it increases with beta
for the statistical notion however now
the bias is measured as being negative
because
since the bias is against females but in
this scenario females have higher
qualifications the fact that the
statistical notion of fairness does not
separate between these differing sources
of bias
leads to a very different
a very different interpretation of
whether the model is actually biased
in contrast if we have at baseline that
the males have higher qualifications
than the females in this scenario the
statistical notion of fairness
significantly overestimates on the level
of unfairness in comparison to the
causal pre
and so the major takeaways
from this work are first that
causal analysis at different points can
help identify
more precisely specific sources of
disparities and distinguish between them
parity-based causal and statistical
fairness notions converge when we don't
have disparities in the baseline
attributes
but they
do diverge when it comes to
differing baselines
and in those contexts the statistical
notions of fairness either over or
underestimate the level of unfairness
as a result statistical fairness is not
capable of distinguishing unfairness at
each of these different time points
and ultimately our framework also
underscores the need for data sets that
span this decision-making pipeline so
in our synthetic example we were able to
very specifically distinguish
what were pre-treatment variables versus
poached treatment and separate out the
interview score as well
in practice that can often be difficult
to distinguish especially when gender
or whatever your sensitive attribute is
is perceived at various points in the
decision making process and so having
data that can help you delineate that
can be quite critical for distinguishing
whether the bias is due to one part of
the process versus another part um so
that's the first paper and i see there's
um a question in the chat oh ten minutes
left yep thanks okay i will speed things
up with the second presentation
um okay so let me see yes i'll go
through this very quickly then um so
this is human-centric visual diversity
auditing um this is joint work with
drone andrews and shamik joniak
who are also
on the sony ai team and shimak was our
intern over the summer
so basically um some to set some context
for this work um so when we talk about
fairness in the tabular data context
we're often worried about these
discriminatory trends in our data
in the computer vision context typically
the primary problem driving unfairness
is
lack of diversity in our data sets and
this is just one example illustrating
this so on the left hand side we have
the original image in the middle we have
a down sampled image and on the right
hand side we
have applied a model to reconstruct the
face and we can see that the right hand
images have ended up looking much more
caucasian and much more male in
comparison to the left-hand images and
this is due to biases
in the
um
in the model that in the face
restoration model which has seen far
more images of males and caucasian
individuals than of um female or darker
skinned individuals
and so um even though diversity in human
image data sets is a very critical
concern for fairness it's quite
difficult in practice to actually
achieve diversity so the canonical way
that people approach this at the moment
is
to discretize certain demographic
categories so usually people think of
gender race and age
and then to try to guarantee parity
across these different groups so equal
number of images in each of these groups
and this has a number of shortcomings so
first off
this does not necessarily capture all of
the visual diversity we would be
interested in so for example on the
right hand side we see images that all
fall under this caucasian female 20 to
39 bucket but it's a very homogeneous
looking set of images
so
using these categories doesn't
necessarily capture all the diversity
we're interested in
and then in addition to that oftentimes
in research people assume that we have
access to labeled information about
people's demographics and this is
typically not actually true in practice
and so often this involves
relying on human annotators to create
these labels and of course that
then in turn adds additional layers of
bias
also makes it quite difficult for people
who might not
fit very neatly within your demographic
taxonomy to be seen
so for example if you discretize
gender into just male and female on
people who are non-binary will not um be
necessarily featured appropriately or
people who are multi-ethnic might not be
captured
with a simple race characterization
um so instead what we do in this paper
is we try to train a model to actually
um learn
a facial embedding space of what
dimensions people think are relevant for
facial similarity and then we use this
model to be able to generate diversity
scores for human image data sets
and so the
intuition behind how we do this is so we
have these triplets of human face images
and we ask people to choose to odd one
out so obviously which
person looks the least similar to the
other two
and by doing this we are implicitly
learning the different dimensions that
people think are relevant for judging
facial similarity so for example
for the first triplet you can imagine
that maybe people would think the middle
image is the odd one out because of a
hair color difference versus in the
second
triplet people might pick the third
image
due to differences in gender and age
compared to the other two
and so
through all of these triplet judgments
we're able to identify these relevant
dimensions
and so the basic idea is that
our model is learning these face
embeddings that hopefully should capture
the various dimensions that people are
implicitly using and in this way we're
not requiring folks to explicitly label
the images but instead to reflect upon
just visual similarity
and in order to actually test whether
the dimensions our model learns are
actually meaningful
question from the audience to mind uh
oh yeah yeah
hi alice and
in this
method that you have for
evaluating diversity
it seems like it's circular because you
need the diversity in the triplets that
you are presenting
so
if you don't have diversity enough
diversity in the triplets of images that
you show then you will never be able to
get diversity in the outcome
so it's somehow you you are
using as input the type of
outcome that you would like to get i
mean it's it looks a bit circular
so some diversity is required in the
training data set for this but one
advantage of our approach is you can the
model can't extrapolate beyond the
diversity that it has seen um in that it
basically learns these dimensions that
are relevant for diversity but you could
have you know scores of diversity that
are higher than what was actually seen
in the training data set
way of formally stating it
um in the in the paper
we do
um
but um
but yeah if all triplets will be
white
people between the age of 20 and 30
then you will never
figure out diversity with respect to
older people or black people because
they haven't been shown in the triplets
yeah so you need every relevant
type of feature to be represented
in the data set but you don't
necessarily need the whole spectrum so
for example if you have zero diversity
at all in skin tone in the training set
then it of course cannot learn that skin
tone is relevant but if you have
some degree of diversity so let's say
you have fitzpatrick scale
two to four but you don't have one to
six it can still learn that skin tone is
relevant and then you know that if you
do later on have
images that have a wider range of skin
tone that that is a more diverse set
um but
yeah you do need to have at least some
degree of diversity
in that dimension in the training set
um so yeah um
so just to quickly run through um this
part over here so basically um so after
we trained this model our goal was to
try to see whether these dimensions are
meaningful or human interpretable and so
for each dimension what we did was
we arranged them in descending order and
then first we asked human participants
to label these dimensions so basically
to have one to three labels of how they
would characterize this dimension
um and then afterward we um created word
clouds in terms of what sorts of um
labels people tend to ascribe to them
and so here you can see um you know some
some of the categories that emerged did
seem quite similar to what people often
think of in terms of demographic
categories so you have like male
female
black caucasian east asian south asian
and elderly
but we also did find certain dimensions
that were not what we typically see in a
lot of you know demographic labels and
so we have dimensions around people's
facial shapes people's facial
expressions facial hair
and also whether their hair was dyed or
not so there's also these other implicit
dimensions of diversity that people are
using for judging whether faces are
similar that you know might not be
included otherwise if we are just
labeling um the dimensions
via demographics
and the second approach we took was to
again for each dimension have um have
images
um ordered in descending order and then
to introduce a novel image and ask human
participants to place this novel image
somewhere along
the spectrum
and then to compare that to where our
model would place it
and we found that there was a pretty
high correlation between where humans
would place it versus where the model
would place it which
further affirmed to us that there was
something on that our model was learning
that it maps onto how humans would judge
similarity and that these dimensions
were capturing something that is human
interpretable
and then finally the last thing we
looked at here was of course one of the
original motivations for this is we
wanted to
sidestep some issues of annotator bias
that come with explicitly labeling
demographics but we were still worried
about the extent to which there might be
annotator bias so we also checked for
that here and we did find that if we
used the annotator specific mask and
included that in our model it did
improve our model's performance and so
that does imply that there is
information in the annotator specific
mask
and this also does imply that different
people
see different dimensions as being of
different levels of importance for
judging facial similarity
and then finally we checked to see
whether there were systematic
differences here and we did find that
their worst
were differences um in terms of
how people weighed different dimensions
depending on if they were male or female
european or asian and also depending on
their age
so this further affirms that it's quite
important to have a very diverse set of
annotators and also to be quite aware of
potential annotator biases because there
isn't necessarily you know one way of
determining whether um different faces
look more similar or different
so
sorry for that very well whirlwind
set of two frozen stations but hopefully
that
hopefully that gave you a bit of a
flavor for both of these papers and
happy to answer any questions if we have
time
terrific um thank you so much alice i
don't see questions in chat yet and ben
is going to help us if there are
questions in the room
i have a question here from jordan
hi so i'm curious in the end does this
allow you to do better on the task you
showed us in the beginning the down
sample reconstruct task if for instance
you sort of uh
look at your data and try to make it
more equidistributed in this embedding
that you find do you do better on that
task
um yeah so that's one thing we we still
need to test out but
yes that's one thing we're working on
uh i have a question for you alice i'm
wondering the extent to which you could
talk about some of the differences in an
annotator bias and how those might
relate to research in the social
sciences
that look at kind of people's different
ability to distinguish people who are
outside of their
and i'm putting this in quotes race
racial group ethnic group etc and
whether or not you saw
people focused on kind of more granular
versus more
i don't know nuance differences among
people or what sort of reflections you
might have on that
yeah definitely so that's basically some
of what we're doing for the next phase
of this work to get more of a
qualitative sense of what are these
differences in terms of how different
groups might care about different
features um so i can't say yet in terms
of you know what exactly our findings
are there
but i will say we are um
very interested in this in part because
of all of that cognitive science
literature that implies that that is the
case and also that you know people
might see greater um
might have a harder time distinguishing
different people of different races
compared to different people of their
same race and so um if you don't have a
sufficiently diverse set of annotators
in this case that might for example lead
to a prioritization of characteristics
that might distinguish say different
caucasian individuals if the annotator
group was predominantly caucasian
um
so i think you know
no precise answers yet on that front but
definitely um an interesting area that's
been opened up by this work
any other questions in the room ben
i think uh no i have a question but i'll
save it to the panel discussion okay
we are a few minutes behind so i think
we're gonna take a coffee break and are
we gonna reconvene ben and zach at
in at the half hour or in 24 minutes or
what i think 10 30 would be good okay
great thank you so much alice
thank you thank you
you